[Música]
gracias por continuar con nosotros en 5
minutos con nos acompaña a diana oviedo
coordinadora de operaciones de la
federación internacional de sociedades
de la cruz roja en el centro américa
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros es
una señora oviedo en cinco minutos con
en france 24 ante la llegada del huracán
eta en américa central y las muertes y
destrucción que han sido registradas
hasta el momento como opera la cruz roja
en los países más afectados
bueno buen día muchísimas gracias por
tenerme en su programa la cruz roja
trabaja a través de sus sociedades
nacionales de la mano con los líderes
locales y las autoridades locales para
atender la emergencia
en centroamérica el huracán golpeó
nicaragua con una categoría 4 y se ha
desplazado en honduras del día jueves y
se espera que salga el día de hoy
viernes hasta el noroeste del mar caribe
cruz roja a través de sus filiales y a
través de los voluntarios que están en
el terreno están apoyando las labores de
evacuación las labores de rescate de
personas atrapadas por las inundaciones
y también están apoyando la respuesta la
asistencia directa a las personas que
han sido afectadas
se está trabajando también en los otros
países como guatemala feliz de panamá
en la divulgación de mensajes de
prevención y protección ante la
inminente a este sistema y las
afectaciones por lluvias que están
afectando de hecho toda la región de
centroamérica desde panamá está feliz
ahora como ustedes que analizan esta
ayuda y como la jerarquizan
bueno la ayuda es prestada a través de
nuestras sociedades nacionales de las
cruces rojas de cada uno de los países y
a través de sus filiales a nivel local
contamos con
a nivel local con la presencia de
voluntarios y voluntarias que prestan de
forma desinteresada a sus servicios para
llevar la ayuda a quienes más lo
necesitan cuando más lo necesitan los
fondos también se canalizan a través de
la federación de hecho la federación ha
dispuesto un apoyo para 10.000 personas
en nicaragua que espero el primer país
golpeado y en las próximas horas vamos a
llevar a cabo llamamientos para honduras
y para nicaragua que básicamente la
gestión de fondos internacionales para
atender esta emergencia y en el resto de
los países igual se están canalizando
fondos a través de federación las
sociedades nacionales también captan
fondos a nivel local puede ser del
sector privado de otras organizaciones
internacionales o donantes que estén
presentes diana como ha sido la
coordinación y la comunicación con estos
gobiernos
bueno realmente todos los gobiernos de
la región y en colaboración y en
coordinación con el centro de prevención
de desastres naturales de centroamérica
el cpd nac han estado desarrollando
labores de preparación previo a la
llegada y también ahorita están en
coordinación en cada uno de los países y
bueno la federación como tal y las
sociedades nacionales de cruz roja pues
cumplen un rol auxiliar de los estados y
hay estrecha coordinación y comunicación
tanto a nivel regional como a nivel
local para sobre todo para que sea una
respuesta efectiva así es diana ya una
última pregunta antes de despedirla
cuáles son las acciones más urgentes en
medio de esta emergencia
bueno lo más urgente es atender a
alojamiento medio de vida también no
descuidar el tema de salud porque
sabemos que cuando se presentan
inundaciones hay otras enfermedades que
se pueden presentar como diarreas
afecciones en la piel afecciones
respiratorias no olvidemos que estamos
en medio de una pandemia y hay que
asegurar la protección tanto de las
personas que están prestando asistencia
como de las personas asistidas con
medidas de protección personal equipo de
protección personal mascarillas
desinfectantes y las personas que han
sido afectadas sobre todo en sus
viviendas y que se encuentran en
albergues necesitan asistencia inmediata
de alimentación y asegurar las medidas
de protección en estos albergues eso es
lo más inmediato diana muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en cinco
minutos con herediano viario
coordinadora de operaciones de la
federación internacional de sociedades
de la cruz roja en centroamérica
hablando de la llegada del huracán está
ahora convertida en tormenta tropical a
esta región hasta aquí nuestro programa
el día de hoy
nos vemos en una próxima oportunidad
[Música]